i know you were instrumental in bringing
about a ceasefire in georgia
how badly does this country need a
ceasefire right now
but it's one of these moments when you
know idealism meets realism
i just don't see that ceasefire coming
and the reasons are very simple i think
the stakes for vladimir putin are too
high in georgia it was fairly easy to do
that in five days
but i think in ukraine he's looking for
a big war and a big piece and to be
honest if i was president zelensky there
would be very little that you can
compromise on at the moment
do you think um
actually the world has already caused so
much harm to president putin he feels
like he's got nothing to lose is that
why he's after a big war as you put it
well i think you know he has to stay
today and that is historical great
russia which for him
includes belarus and and ukraine so
that's his sort of vision he wants to
create his own legacy you know he wants
to be there with the stalins and the
ivan the terribles and peter the great
so of russia as a great leader and i
don't think he will do anything that
stands in his way to stop it and the
problem of course is that he can't lose
face and he knows that so therefore you
know we're into the fourth week in this
war and he's not looking extremely good
and probably getting increasingly
desperate as well
so so what are his options now what you
know what will his end game look like
it's very difficult to say i mean i
think there are three options in this
conflict as there quite often are one is
the withdrawal of russian troops
um obviously he's not looking for that
the other one is to split ukraine into
two eastern and west
ukraine and the ukrainians will never
allow that to happen and thirdly is that
he goes all the way and tries to take
over ukraine so i think all of the
options i mean the first one is is the
one that i'd love to see but the two
other ones are are quite horrific to be
honest uh but you know as i said earlier
you know i think this is going to be a
protracted long-term conflict so we're
not talking only about weeks but most
probably months
well it is already horrific as you know
so how do you hold on to a nation
when they begin to hate you
uh for putin
you know obviously you have a couple of
things there you have to remember that
in the dna of of russian culture and
history is this sentiment that the rest
of the world is against russia and
russia is isolated and surrounded you
know attacked from the east by the
mongols in the olden days and now by
served formerly by the nazis and not now
by the westerners so there is this sort
of psyche that you know what's going on
as we we have to fight for for russia
and russian identity but of course it's
going to be a combination of things so
one is the sanctions
you know country that is moving towards
a potential default uh the other one is
the fact that ukraine might be able to
push push back but in russia what you
need is basically a bottom-up uh
movement to get rid of any leader that
that you have and i i think this has to
come from the inside we can't force
change
well what about that idea of pushing
back then how do you see the ukrainians
fighting this and how do you reckon
they've gone so far and how does it
compare with what finland did back in
1939
yeah i mean there are some elements
obviously of the winter war 1939 lasted
for
101 days and there's this sort of
sentiment
almost of heroic nostalgia when we're
watching the ukrainians fighting and the
parallels are there and are not the
parallels that are is that when you're
attacked by a big aggressor for us it
was a soviet union for ukraine it's
russia your sort of sentiment of of
defending and protecting your country
goes beyond the call of duty so to speak
whereas the attacker in other words the
russian soldiers some of them are
wondering you know what are we actually
doing here why are we doing this
the second one is that they are now
being fed
with arms
with financial aid with humanitarian aid
and the longer this goes on the more
convinced i am
that actually uh ukraine and president
zielinski
can push back uh and in that sense
things are not looking very good for
putin this is only an educated guess i'm
not a military expert
well they can push back are you actually
suggesting you think the ukrainians can
win this
well again this is where idealism meets
realism and i can't give you an answer
on that but i would argue that if you're
looking at victory over the hearts minds
and souls of the rest of the world the
ukrainians have already done that and if
you're looking at defeat in terms of
showing the weakness of your military
then putin has already done that
so in in that sense i would argue that
ukrainians have already won but then the
final issue here is the end state you
know is
are they going to be able to
maintain the independence and
sovereignty of ukraine
and its territory that's that's going to
be the key
we were just seeing a piece there from
ireland
questioning their own neutrality you
know where does finland stand on this on
nato neutrality and all those questions
that have been prompted by this war
well i i certainly wouldn't compare
finnish and irish neutrality because
ours
during the cold war was one of necessity
with 1 340 kilometers of border
with russia
when the cold war ended we immediately
ditched the notion of neutrality joined
the european union joined the euro
a very close partnership with nato
participate in nato operations and also
in nato training our military is more
nato compatible than that of many member
states and we were very quick to send
arms to ukraine as well
but this has obviously shifted public
opinion on nato membership you know we
used to be 50 against 24. now the latest
opinion post 62 in favor of nato
membership and 16 against so if i may
predict with my academic glasses on the
train has left the station and
eventually finland will join nato
very interesting um so many implications
from this conflict certainly professor
alexander stubb former prime minister of
finland thank you very much indeed for
your time much appreciated
my pleasure